when they say 2% milk I don't know what
the other 98% is andy dwyer
you're a simple guy and that's what
makes you so hilarious you've kept
Leslie Knope and your entire office on
their toes with your one-liners you are
always there when they needed a hand
although sometimes you weren't on the
same page as everyone else still that
never stopped April Ludgate from hanging
off your every word
tons of actors are famous for their
wicked improvisation skills from Chris
Pratt to Jennifer Aniston to Will Smith
keep watching to find out which sitcom
actor improvised one of the most
emotional scenes on TV no improbably
give me the money back my script says to
rip it up and walk away dramatically How
I Met Your Mother
we're starting off with a very emotional
scene and believe it or not but it was
100% authentic Jason Segel who portrayed
Marshall on How I Met Your Mother
is one incredible actor his acting
skills know no bounds and one of the
most moving scenes in the series takes
place in season 6 episode 13 when Lily
informs Marshall that his father has
passed away after suffering a heart
attack if Marshalls reaction seemed a
little too genuine it's because it was
as it turns out Jason Segel hadn't read
the final scripts yet he had no idea
that his on-screen wife Lily played by
Alyson Hannigan was going to throw some
heartbreaking news his way jason had to
improvise that entire scene which made
it all the more believable anyone who
watched How I Met Your Mother knows that
Marshall and his father Marvin had a
very close relationship
so this news came as a total surprise on
a lighter note did you know that Marvin
Eriksen was played by actor Bill Fagor
baki
the man responsible for voicing
Patrick's star George this is us this is
us is one emotional roller coaster ride
it shows us the ins and outs of family
and how even the most put together
people can be hurting on the inside
sterling K Brown does an amazing job of
portraying Randall Pierson Kate and
Kevin's adopted triplet fitting in
wasn't always easy for Randall
which is why meeting his biological
father was such a big deal although no
one could ever replace his adoptive
father Jack getting to know William Hill
helped Randall get closer to his roots
most of the time the cast of this is us
sticks to their scripts but this wasn't
the case while filming the episode
titled Memphis in this episode Randall
and his father will who was played by
Ron Cephas Jones enter a barbershop to
get their hair cut and they exchange
stories about their first barbershop
experiences no forget him because he's
always threatened to cut my usual
if this scene seemed a little too smooth
it's because it was sterling and Ron
improvised this entire conversation they
spoke freely about the real first
haircut and producers let the cameras
roll Sherlock
Benedict Cumberbatch and Martin Freeman
take the stage as Sherlock Holmes and
dr. John Watson and the TV series
Sherlock here we meet a very serious
Sherlock Holmes who wants nothing more
than to solve crimes and put criminals
away but in the episode titled the sign
of three Sherlock and John finally let
loose when they go out to celebrate
John's bachelor party they have more
than a few drinks and they're having a
blast
that is until duty calls Holmes and
Watson take on a case in their
inebriated state which makes for a very
funny episode they usually composed teen
tries to keep it together while looking
for clues but they fail miserably during
a Q&A with Steven Moffat the co-writer
revealed that one of the episodes
funniest line to actually stemmed from a
mishap Benedict had failed to remember
his lines during the consultation scene
instead of saying his line Benedict went
on to say but instead of yelling cut
directors kept the cameras rolling
considering Sherlock's state it was
fitting that the character forgot what
he was apologizing for crime scene the
office the cast at the office was no
stranger to ad-lib moments in fact the
actors were encouraged to speak freely
during their one-on-one moments with the
camera Steve Carell and Rainn Wilson who
played Michael Scott and Dwight Schrute
respectively were particularly famed for
going off script
in fact directors have said that rain
improvises seemed more often than not
but one of the funniest scenes in the
office history didn't include rain at
all but rather Oscar and Michael this
scene occurs in season 3 episode 1 when
Michael desperately tries to prove that
he is ok with Oscar being a part of the
gbt q community and one of the most
Awkward on-screen moments michael locks
lips with Oscar in front of the entire
office this scene was painful to watch
an Oscar looked absolutely terrified and
rightfully so
after all going the first-base with
Michael hadn't been on the script
Steve Carell was supposed to Peck Oscar
Nunez on the cheek but he chose to go
the extra mile for comedy sake Parks and
Recreation to say that Chris Pratt is a
funny guy it would be an understatement
he delivered some hilarious lines as
Andy Dwyer many of which he came up with
on his own in the episode titled flu
season Andy attempts to help Leslie out
seeing as she's sick and all he types in
her symptoms online determined to give
her a Google diagnosis only to say I
typed your symptoms into the thing up
here and it says you could have network
connectivity problems this simple yet
witty line came straight from Chris
Pratt's imagination and it had viewers
laughing out loud but Chris isn't the
only cast member who is notorious for
winging it on camera nope
the entire cast is well-versed when it
comes to ad-lib moments this was proven
in the episode titled the fight when the
entire cast was asked to improvise their
snakejuice reactions the characters of
the show had taken some very potent
snake juice and their actors improvise
their one-on-one scenes with the camera
turns out Amy Poehler was actually
directing the scene and the actors were
doing their very best to make her laugh
Baba Booey
are you enjoying this video that
subscribe to the things for more we post
daily videos about your favorite movies
TV shows and celebrities so stay in the
loop by clicking that notification bell
if you're watching on your mobile switch
all notifications in your YouTube
settings keep watching to find out which
TV character improvised every single one
of his lines the Game of Thrones Game of
Thrones was one of the most watched TV
series of all time its characters were
brought to life by some of the most
amazing actors in Hollywood while the
majority of the show was scripted a few
of its scenes were ad-libbed
the show was known for having some
brilliant romances but some of these
romances never came to fruition like the
one between tormund Giantsbane and
Brienne of Tarth no matter how hard
torment ride Brienne just wasn't
impressed by him in season 5 episode 6
tormund long flew stares at Brienne
while on horseback and
lashes are his best smile this scene had
viewers smiling from ear-to-ear but did
you know that it wasn't actually
scripted yeah that's right Christopher
hives Jew who plays torment came up with
the scene all on his own another notable
ad-lib moment is brought to us by Iain
Glen who is known for his portrayal of
Jorah Mormont ian was asked to ad-lib
some of his Dothraki lines when the
show's language consultant couldn't make
it to the set another Chad maybe let
Jack alone huh cuz friends Ross Geller
isn't the easiest person to deal with
just ask his three ex-wives broths
getting divorced became a running joke
on the hit sitcom friends I hear divorce
I immediately go to Ross but this joke
wasn't always funny for Rachel who
married Ross in Las Vegas when she was
under the influence
Ross and Rachel get married in the
episode titled the one in Vegas part two
but rachel realizes her mistake and asks
Ross to get an annulment problem is Ross
isn't keen on the idea in the episode
titled the one after Vegas Ross tries to
convince Rachel to stay married to him
which flabbergast sir
Ross is throwing around the word
marriage during their heated argument
and Jennifer Aniston was supposed to say
stop saying the word of marriage but she
chose to switch things up
Jennifer changed her line to and
directors liked it so much they chose it
over the original line The Walking Dead
The Walking Dead has some of the best
characters of all time but only a
handful of them make it past every
season Daryl and Carol are the only
members of the original group to appear
in every single season and they share a
very special bond when we first meet
Carol she's a shell of a person she's
timid afraid and weak but she grows into
one of the show's most powerful
characters and daryl is always there to
lend her a helping hand in season 5
episode 12 we watch as Carol pretends to
be a clueless housewife to fool the
residents of Alexandria she puts on very
conservative clothing and suggests that
Daryl take a shower and do the same but
that just isn't Daryl style Daryl
obviously has a problem with Carol's
soccer-mom attire so much so that Norman
Reedus the actor who portrays him chose
to throw in the line of his own during
the scene as Carol is walking away he
yells out you look ridiculous this line
wasn't in the script but directors chose
to include it anyway scrubs
Scrubs was a sitcom that aired from 2001
to 2010 it had a total of nine seasons
and those who watched it just couldn't
get enough of it
scrub star Donald fasion Sarah Chalke
and Zach Braff and for those of you who
never watched the show it followed a
group of doctors and residents who
worked at the Sacred Heart Hospital
while the majority of the show was
scripted producers encouraged the cast
to improvise their line to whenever they
saw fit and one actor in particular took
this to a whole new level Neil Flynn
portrayed the show's janitor was one of
the very few cast members to improvise
nearly every single one of his lines I
was gone I'm 37 years old and I'm a
janitor how do you think it's going but
this came naturally to Neil who is a
former member of the family a Chicago
based improv troupe Neil appeared in 170
episodes of scrubs and improvised the
vast majority of his lines can I talk to
you for a second no I'm busy cleaning
and as a result Neil's fellow actors had
to take their scripts with a grain of
salt especially when their characters
had a scene with the janitor The Fresh
Prince of bel-air but if there's one
ad-lib scene that will forever stay in
our hearts it's the one brought to us by
Will Smith in the episode titled Papa's
got a brand-new excuse will was asked to
improvise a very heartbreaking scene in
which he talked about his father and how
he never wanted him this TV moment
brought tears to her eyes and Will Smith
later revealed how he drew inspiration
for the scene during an interview with
Black Press Media Group as it turns out
he was pushed by the late actor James
Avery who played his on-screen Uncle
Phil James
encouraged him to deliver a heartfelt
improvised moment James wouldn't settle
until will pushed his acting skills to
the limit and that's exactly what we'll
did when we'll finally emulated what
James had envisioned James hugged him
and whispered now that's acting into his
ear and that's a wrap on the 10
improvised scenes that made it into TV
shows before you go tell us which ad-lib
moment was your favorite in the comments
section below
hit that subscribe button and don't
forget to subscribe to the things
thank you for watching we'll see you
next time